Transcriber: Hala Shmayess
المدقّق: Riyad Altayeb
مساء الخير
موضوع حدث TEDx لليوم هو حكايات الشغف.
لماذا نتكلم جميعًا عن الشغف،
وما هي أهمية الشغف؟
من وجهة نظري الشخصية
الشغف هو الحب، والطاقة التي تحثّك
على العمل على هدف ما
ومع كل نفس تأخذه في حياتك
يكون الشغف موجودًا.
قد يقول لك البعض:
انسَ هذا الشغف وجد عملًا ينفعك.
لماذا؟
لأنهم يظنون أن الشغف
هو مشاعر فقط
والمشاعر تتغير.
لكن لا، الشغف أعمق من ذلك بكثير.
وأنا هنا اليوم لأخبركم بمغامراتي
التي تثبت ذلك.
عندما كان عمري تسع سنوات
بدأت بتعلم البرمجة.
كتبت آلاف الأسطر، وشاركت
بالكثير من المسابقات البرمجية.
فزت في العديد منها،
وقد كان ذلك رائعًا
وخسرت في مسابقات أخرى،
ولم يكن ذلك بروعة الفوز
لكني تعلمت من كليهما،
من الفوز والخسارة.
لماذا؟ لأني استمتعت بكليهما.
كنت أعلم أني أفعل ما أريده في الحياة.
بدأت القصة بأكلمها منذ عشرة سنوات
عندما جلستُ بالقرب من أختي
وكانت تكتب أشياءً على الحاسوب
ولم أكن أفهم ماذا يحدث وقتها.
ضغطت على زر، وكتبت أشياءً أخرى
ثم صرخت بفرح: إنها تعمل!
استغربتُ وقتها لأني لم أكن أفهم ماذا يحدث.
بالنسبة لي، ما فعلته أختي
مع الحاسوب كان سحرًا.
بعد فترة من الزمن فهمت
أن ما كانت أختي تفعله يسمى برمجة.
في تلك اللحظة عرفت ما أريد
أن أكونه في هذه الحياة
أريد أن أكون مبرمجًا.
أريد أن أصبح ساحرًا!
ومنذ ذلك الحين بدأت أختي بتعليمي.
ومن خلال تجاربي والأشخاص الذين عملت معهم
عرفت أن البرمجة والخوارزميات
هي شغفي في الحياة.
لماذا؟ لماذا البرمجة هي شغفي في الحياة؟
إذا فكرنا للحظة سندرك أن البرمجة
وعلوم الحاسوب ليست اختصاصًا جديدًا.
لأن جميع المفاهيم البرمجية
نابعة من الرياضيات
والرياضيات نابعة من الفلسفة
والفلسفة نابعة من حاجتنا
لأن نفهم حياتنا بأكملها.
فإذا تتبعنا هذه العلاقة
سندرك أن البرمجة نابعة من حياتنا
ومن حاجتنا لها.
كل هذه الأشياء جعلتني أرغب
بأن أكون مبرمجًا.
لم أخبركم بعد عن متعة الإنجاز.
منذ سنة، وبعد سنة طويلة من النجاحات
والإخفاقات والتجارب المختلفة
تعلمت شيئًا مهمًا جدًا.
شيئًا يعتقد الناس أنهم يعلمونه،
لكنهم في الحقيقة لا يدركونه
وهو أن امتلاكك للشغف
ليس الشرط الوحيد للنجاح،
لكن يعتمد الأمر أيضًا على مقدار
إيمانك والتزامك به،
ومقدار الإرادة التي تمتلكها
لتعمل بجد وتبذل جهًدا حتى تصل
إلى ذلك الهدف.
خلال السنة الماضية فقدت شغفي
في بعض الأحيان.
كما فقدت إيماني بأهدافي
التي كنت أعمل عليها.
مما أفقدني التركيز والالتزام والإرادة
لأن أعمل بجد وأبذل جهدًا
لأصل إلى هدفي.
لكني مؤمن اليوم بأنك إن ركزت
والتزمت وامتلكت الإرادة
فسوف تصل إلى ذلك الهدف.
كمثال على ذلك، قام إيلون ماسك
منذ عشرة سنوات
بسحب جميع أمواله من باي بال
وقام باستثمار هذه الأموال في ثلاث شركات
وفي ثلاث صناعات مختلفة،
كما اضطر لاستئجار منزل للعيش فيه،
لأنه كان قد باع منزله.
لكنه كان يتبع شغفه، كما كان لديه هدف معين
يؤمن به وملتزم بتحقيقه
ولديه الإرادة لأن يبذل مجهودًا
في سبيل الوصول إلى هدفه.
واليوم بعد حوالي عشر سنوات
تفاجئنا تلك الشركات بإنجازات جديدة كل يوم
وقد تجاوزت ثروة إيلون ماسك 13 مليار.
لذلك، انهض واخرج بحثًا عن شغفك في العالم
واتبعه ولا تتركه أبدًا.
اعتبره كابن صغير لك،
واجعل من غوغل صديقًا مقربًا لك.
واعمل بجد قدر الإمكان لتصل إلى ذلك الهدف.
(تصفيق)
and the biggest risk
is not taking any risks
تعني هذه العبارة: "إن أكبر مخاطرة
هي ألا تخاطر أبدًا"
وهو ما قاله مارك زاكربيرغ في أحد الأيام.
لذلك خاطر بقيامك بعمل مميز،
حتى لو علمت أنه سيفشل
لأنك ستتعلم الكثير من الأشياء المختلفة
التي لن يستطيع أي أحد آخر تعليمك إياها.
قف للحظة وفكر: "من أنا بالنسبة إلى العالم؟
وما الذي أستطيع تقديمه للبشرية؟"
ومن المهم جدًا ألا تدع أحدًا يشوشك.
أتذكرون عندما قلت أني بدأت بتعلم البرمجة
عندما كان عمري تسع سنوات؟
إذًا لماذا لا أقول أني مبرمج محترف؟
لأن رحلة التعلم تبدأ في كل يوم.
شكرًا.